hi I'm Erik Bosse in Toy Story 4 found a
new way to use increasingly
photo-realistic animation to break our
hearts but also to remind us that it's
ok to feel like trash and to choose to
be homeless that's the message you
intended right Pixar ok yeah but if you
stick around through the credits of this
movie it actually features several
mid-credits scenes and a post-credits
scene so i'm gonna break down the indian
of Toy Story for its deeper meaning and
how the in credits Clips button up the
story's so perfectly squirrel running we
haven't seen Toy Story 4 yet what's it
doing here okay and the final act of Toy
Story woody and Bo Peep have rescued
forky from the antique shop but this
rescue was more of a group team-up the
movie's apparent antagonist was the doll
Gaby Gaby who thought that if she could
just get Woody's functioning voice box
the girl harmony would love her
tragically harmony turned out to be
quite a little bee but during this
escape to Bonnie's family RV in the
carnival Gaby spots a crying lost kid
and woody and Bo help her comfort the
kid so in doing so woody find a new
purpose which is what Toy Story 4 is all
about Woody's existence has always been
about caring for a kid Andi and then
Bonnie but when Bonnie neglected woody
in favor of a trash toy that she made
Woody's new journey was to redefine
himself and not be tethered to a kid
really it's a metaphor for retirement
Woody's first dust bunny in the closet
which the other old toys suggested he
should name tumbleweed is like a gray
hair or a new soreness that you didn't
have the morning before or a new
medication want us to take for that
soreness how do we let go and move on
from our lifelong functions that we've
always had and give ourselves a new
purpose so that we don't just become
obsolete in Woody's case that new
purpose is to help other toys find their
forever kids like an adoption services
social worker because that's what
Woody's always been best at knowing how
therapeutic otoi can be for a kid he
mentioned earlier how soothing Bo Peep
was for Molly when she was a baby and he
and Gabby both claimed to have been
built in the 1950s meaning that woody
could have been sitting around for
decades before Andy gave his life
meaning so woody applies this lesson in
the final scenes he helps Gabby find a
new forever kid he helps porky get back
to Bonnie he also passes on his
sheriff's patch to Jesse since Jesse was
the cowboy doll that Bonnie preferred
playing with so without this badge and
without the pull-string that gave him a
voice woody metaphorically
and literally severs his ties to any
specific human and he frees himself to
move on
Buzz Lightyear says goodbye with to
infinity and woody completes it with and
beyond redefining these words as Woody's
destiny to go beyond his familiar
routine now the mid credit scenes
reinforce this deeper meaning woody
joined by beau ducky and bunny free the
other toys from the carnival booth
including a pair of frog toys one by one
woody lives up to his retirement by
reconnecting toy after toy with kids and
reducing the playing of lost neglected
toys because as we saw with lot so they
can get pretty homicidal when left alone
they do this until the carny turns
around and the booth is empty at this
point we get one last scene with ducky
and bunny with actors Jordan Peele and
keegan-michael key catching him again on
their recurring + Ross gag attacking the
carnie growing two kaijus eyes while
destroying the carnival with lasers but
we cut back to this just being a pitched
by ducky and bunny to do kaboom voiced
by Keanu Reeves who asks if they can
really shoot lasers out of their eyes
they're like yeah and Reeves gives his
signature Wow
then the credits pause briefly to check
in with Bonnie returning from school
with Jessie paralleling Woody's earlier
introduction of for ki now with Bonnie's
new homemade trash toy knifey Nike says
trash in the same kind of existential
crisis that four key began the movie
with and then she asks why am i alive
and forkie responds I don't know it's
hilarious but it's also what this
movie's theme is these toys no longer
have to assume that they exist purely
for the joy of a child it's on these
toys themselves to define what their own
purposes and destinies are then the
credits continue and roll down to these
sweet tributes to the late Don Rickles
the actor who voiced mr. Potato Head who
passed away and - Adam Burke the Pixar
animator who passed away last October he
worked on Toy Story three cars - and
Incredibles - but the final post-credits
scene at the very end of the credits
closes out with one of the best jokes of
the film Dooku boom rolls out on a Pixar
studio car door play scene the luxo jr.
lamp and now Duke bounces his motorcycle
on the letter I strikes as midair poses
and then amazingly Arctic combat Carl
returns the combat Carl's for the GI Joe
action figures for the playground
earlier all voiced by the actor Carl
Weathers they high-five each other
except Arctic combat Carl who sadly is
always left hanging but in the final
seconds duke always the plate connect
finally gives Arctic combat Carl
the high-five he's been so desperate for
comment down below with your thoughts on
Toy Story 4 or follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at ei vas and subscribe to
me rockstars for deep dives into Pixar
and all your favorite animated films and
how Pixar is secretly dart as help
[Music]